Oh what's going on YouTube uh I did it
again like I said every now and then
I'll make a video that's a bit
ridiculous as you can tell by the title
already us about Street balling I love
falling personally I love basketball
I've whooping it up um am I good at it
learning you're boomers and in my area
everybody likes the ball every time you
step on the court there's always like
three people that always call you at the
ball and they always pretend like
they're not good at basketball no flour
you play one loody loody loody play do
it layup I miss the ball I missed the
ball and then when you actually start to
play they actually really good in your
face little [ __ ] so much specifically
one of it happened that uh that
particularly traumatized me and sir you
know who you are who did this to me you
little [ __ ] I was played at 24 hour
fitness yes the gym don't see [ __ ] don't
make a joke I was going down the court
running down this guy comes up crosses
me over makes me fall he whispers a
little [ __ ] in my ear and he goes up
and he lays the ball up now that wasn't
the problem the problem was we were on
the same team you notice or anything was
also scared that I actually apologized
to him my bad I won't do that again
I won't trip to fall on my face again
man but my bed my mother what anyways go
ahead and check this clip out yeah it's
um it's interesting
basketball it's not it's not all about
you know practicing your skills you know
practicing every day it's all about
three things really to shooter sleeves
one headband it's all you need sweat
wipe it away wipe it away I stay out
here you know on the court this is where
I live you know I was born with this
[ __ ] in my hand is the first [ __ ] that
came out stick it out my mama like this
this dude always comes up on this court
if you talking hella [ __ ] we let me tell
you something about basketball guess
what NBA stands for National Basketball
Association ah no [ __ ] is allowed I'm
always out here and this dude come up to
me and he's wearing his headband hello
do for you his head sticking all out he
had to shooting sleeves and asked me if
I want to play keep telling me to hold
his dick I like that
Oh buddy bring all the hip hop over be
holding the only thing that's foul on
this court is attitude home you feel me
hey time blocker shot foul
batfish come on man damn house clean
Manzo boys jump out and time I post up
spool it's flopping like a Shaquille
O'Neal well pal
are you tail I dribble he falls get off
with me me backing it up with his big
ass African booty knocking me over and
he over saying Dana foul we don't pee
honey like giraffes and zebras over here
you know I'm saying this is a real talk
I may be dressed like a zebra I mean
playing like a zebra I don't know what's
up this dude but his trash talk goes up
to the next level I don't know where it
comes from
I looked through his back history I
looked at his birth certificate you
ain't got to talk about his skills
really but you need your deeper person
some time on your family table I my mama
talking my daddy your mama got your boys
get a little fat [ __ ] [ __ ] that you
use condom talk about my skin complexion
I'm a bit confused on my plate you will
share a is a [ __ ] but my skin color mask
uh-oh y'all be sending me [ __ ] man
man I go by yourself he stabbed me you
know homey be talking about you know I
ain't a real basketball player because I
stand in the stuff like that
the real talk look at his basketball hey
guys it is original color on it see I'm
a real baller because my ball is su I'm
saying if you're balling ashy
you ain't class
ain't no blood no foul being weighted
[ __ ] oh hey you hold the whip whip ice
gang [ __ ] y'all go game though man
wish it I swear yo hey yo may we have a
shoot sleep pictures nah nah man that's
good you very much copy like no [ __ ]
but I recommend a most Korean nobody
like me Kim Jong neither my spontaneity
to prowl
okay I grew up to be a beauty and now I
shade everybody under my power
you know you know that one thank you
lucky you uh you got more skill than you
fast and you stronger and taller than me
[ __ ] come around here no and beat me in
basketball get that right whoo